un gros débat sur le sexisme à la
télévision et dans le cinéma mais pour
l'instant c'est Natacha Amal qui est
avec nous merci beaucoup merci à vous et
là pour voir Natacha franchement j'aime
beaucoup je suis content qui me dit mais
moi j'aimerais bien vous preniez comme
chroniqueuse c'est une blague ou non
mais c'est parce que vous avez dit juste
avant oui j'ai voulu de vous plein de
fois dans la relation et vous avez
refusé je dis mais je sais même pas au
courant
de chroniqueuse mais en vrai évidemment
Natacha énormément star je parle 2000
2009 la série femme d'honneur ou la
femme de loi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous en doutez bien voilà avec Eric
Chauvin vous vous êtes resté pendant 9
années ingrid est parti pour la 6e année
les petites questions qui m'a été payées
dans le plat à prendre plus mais c'est
vrai que ça a pas été longtemps il y
avait de stars et ça c'est ça pas pris
entre vous non ça a été enfin je dirais
que au contraire les premières années
ont été absolument idylliques on
s'entendait vraiment comme de frangines
on s'amusait beaucoup c'est une époque
où on rigolait encore dans le travail
et donc et puis et puis après non elle a
eu un énorme succès et j'en félicite et
ça un petit peu colorer nos relations on
va dire mais parce que honnêtement parce
que elle ce qu'elle dit je vous
interview elle dit d'abord c'est vrai
qu'on se parle plus et elle dit à
l'époque Natacha était jalouse de mon
succès c'était ça à ma grande surprise
mais c'est elle qui a changé ou c'est
vous qui avez un petit peu de jalousie
non non j'ai vraiment découvert ces
déclaration
et après coup j'ai même eu une
discussion avec notre ancien directeur
tu vois de qui je parle et je lui ai dit
je pense que le directeur de la fiction
de tes frères et je dis je voilà
dit rien et moi non plus et donc et j'ai
dit je lui ai dit écoute je pense que
j'étais j'avais vraiment la tête dans le
guidon et enfin le nez dans le guidon je
sais plus que cela merci dans le guidon
et je n'ai pas vu qu'il y avait un
calcul de carrière derrière d'accord et
que ce n'était pas
pratique je pense dans ce calcul là de
briller à deux il faut être un tout
petit peu manipulateur pour faire une
belle carrière je dis ça sans aucun
animateurs pour tout le monde faut être
un petit peu manipulateur vous vous êtes
allé comme ça avec toute la l'innocence
qui était parce que vous étiez deux
jolies femmes deux jolies femmes du même
âge on va dire de jolies femmes du même
âge et elle elle était un peu plus
manipulatrice peut-être elle faisait les
bons déjeuner les bons dîner là où vous
vous étiez un peu je sais pas
pas dans son sac à main j'ai
tout à l'heure
je voulais juste savoir est-ce que c'est
la prod qui a favorisé Ingrid justement
parce qu'elle était plus séductrice que
vous vous êtes plus rentre dedans
sur une grille et est-ce que vous vous
aimez un peu au garage et on a voulu en
faire une grille de ce qu'elle est
devenue et vous vous a mis de côté
non ça ça n'avait rien à voir
non un moment donné on est arrivé à un
niveau qui qui était probablement
surprenant déjà pour nous-mêmes
de célébrités et que je pense que
il y a une il y a un une donnée qui qui
échappe peut-être à beaucoup de gens il
y a l'entourage aussi c'est l'entourage
qui commence à vous mettre des idées
dans la tête alors après il me dit donc
tu sais quand même là maintenant au
niveau où tu es faudrait que tu te
détaches un peu faudrait c'est des trucs
qui sont en même temps c'est intéressant
on lui reposait des questions à elle
est-ce que si la série reprenait vous y
retourneriez et elle a dit oui ce qui
prouve plutôt quand même
une complicité vous iriez vous voulez la
série c'est redémarrer et avec elle mais
c'était une super chouette série et
environ une complicité
mais même quand il a commencé même quand
ça a commencé à sentir un peu le roussi
et je me disais mais pourquoi elle est
comme ça mais machin maintenant je vais
balancer une info c'est que la nouvelle
de la fiction ne m'aimez pas
alors je peux en témoigner ça c'est
dingue c'est pas possible et je suis sûr
que depuis elle elle est partie
et en tant que critique c'est vrai
qu'elle avait fait un feuilleton donc ça
vous donne une popularité incroyable et
que toi tu as fait des unités comme
cuisine au beurre et tout que c'est un
apporte jamais la même notoriété et un
bébé pour mes 40 ans et comme elle ne
t'aimait pas effectivement à la place
on s'en fout les gens que le sport moi
non plus mais quand on parle de sexisme
à la télévision
on pense aux et la rivalité entre femmes
il y avait aucune raison tangible je
vous aimez la rivalité peut-être non non
mais je me suis quand même remise en
question je peux parler à quelqu'un qui
me connaît depuis longtemps je me suis
remise en question je me suis dit
peut-être que j'avais j'avais un peu
d'arrogance à l'époque peut-être que
elle elle a imaginé peut-être aussi
ouais peut-être mais franchement ce sont
des choses
très belle mais à quel point ça peut se
jouer après à un détail quelqu'un qui ne
vous aime pas du tout c'est fragile la
télé mais tu as un contrat directeur de
programme tu aimes pas tu sens et c'est
fini ça peut tenir à très peu de choses
et même pas souvent au choix des
téléspectateurs c'est ça le problème
peut bloquer exactement plein d'autres
boîtes
après vous partez aux États-Unis mais
quand vous êtes aux États-Unis vous avez
un amour heureux qui est une amoureuse
et vous vous en parlez dans la preuve
vous l'avez dit j'étais amoureuse deux
fois dans ma vie j'ai fait même marier
avec une femme c'était amoureuse
beaucoup plus souvent que ça mais
beaucoup plus souvent des hommes et il
se trouve que j'ai eu des coups de cœur
et c'est pour ça que j'aime bien les
gens qui disent quand on aime on aime
voilà alors après bien sûr on reste dans
la catégorie bien sûr
donc
voilà je me suis dit voilà ça c'est
quelque chose que je comprends on peut
vraiment avoir un coup de cœur jusqu'à
vous marier vous avez failli vous marier
vous avez dit et alors là alors je
replace le compte
c'est à dire que au départ coup de coeur
amical on se marre explosion de rire à
tout bout de champ etc feeling de malade
et puis la personne me dit ah bah oui en
fait je suis complètement lesbienne et
je fais ben super génial j'adore tout va
bien quoi et puis de fil en aiguille
c'est mais bon je t'aime enfin je t'aime
tellement
comme ami etc puis bon moi j'ai pas de
blocage mais c'est ce que j'adore ni
pour en parler j'en parle dans mon show
en tant que bourgeoise car vous faites
un one man on va parler évidemment vous
vous lâchez autant qu'aujourd'hui et
alors autre histoire d'amour incroyable
mais je dis la presse mais qu'est-ce que
cette histoire de 88 à 96 donc avant
votre premier mari comme ça pas de souci
vous vivez une aventure amoureuse avec
Prince oui
[Applaudissements]
il était beau comme un dieu on fait des
allers Los Angeles
sur deux ans quand même et en
raisonnable deux ans
oui il y a eu des allers-retours j'ai
passé du temps à Minneapolis bien sûr
j'ai j'ai
voulu comme détail croustillant
ouais il était comment alors combien de
fois par semaine c'est les questions de
Mathieu c'est pas ça la question ça y
est le restaurant c'est une star dans le
quotidien au petit déjeuner enfin voilà
c'est comment il était en vrai c'est
quelqu'un qui bossait non-stop pour une
nuit et il se drogue et pas une buvait
pas mais ça s'est fait comment la
rencontre alors c'était le premier le
premier concert de ma vie de concert de
ma vie j'avais des cheveux longs jusque
là d'ailleurs avec des photos que je
vous ai donné à votre production j'avais
des cheveux longs jusque là
brun et j'étais fine comme une anguille
et vous étiez en public en public
c'est-à-dire j'arrive dans la salle on
faisait le pied grue depuis des lustres
à quelqu'un et puis il y a le staff qui
m'attire qui me prend comme ça par le
collet et qui me met dans dans le le
truc VIP ah oui et donc à la deuxième
chanson je reçois il y avait son garde
du corps Gilbert qui qui qui donne un
papier avec son avec un bic parce qu'en
fait il m'avait tendu le micro pour
chanter moi je connaissais aucune de ces
chansons
et tout le monde chantait les paroles
etc etc et dans le micro le papier entre
deux chansons et je lis et j'avais
emmené mes copains avec moi j'avais dit
non non je rentre pas là-dedans si je
peux pas prendre mes potes avec moi donc
mes copains de chaque quoi et et c'était
marqué voilà j'aimerais beaucoup vous
rencontrer non j'aimerais beaucoup vous
rencontrer après le concert etc
rendez-vous dans tel endroit donc je me
suis avec
je l'ai rencontré dans une petite boîte
de nuit à Bruxelles et
c'était assez cocasse et puis et puis
on a passé coquine des grands hôtels la
grande ville non non pas du tout parce
que je l'ai quitté en pleine nuit
j'avais des blocages oui mais enfin je
suis quelqu'un de quand même mon
éducation tiens je suis pas une groupie
qui marie couche Twilight etc non ça
c'était l'éducation de merde que j'avais
eu et donc et donc je me suis dit je
m'en vais et
puis point barre et voilà et donc il est
il m'avait proposé d'aller visiter
machin de partir avec lui dans le scoop
c'est quand même Natacha Amal à planter
je l'ai largué et six mois plus tard six
mois plus tard parce que quand il était
passé chez moi en fait il voulait voir
où je vivais dans une petite piaule de
pourri
sentez le claquette de souris et il
avait vu des des
[Musique]
comment s'appelle les
trucs les mers les cartons
représentatives là pour les mannequins
les combats
et j'avais un composite de mannequin et
il a pris donc il a appelé 6 mois plus
tard mon agence de mannequin et puis qui
m'a contacté qui fait et je suis mon
dieu il va passer
bon bref et puis finalement j'ai reçu un
billet d'avion première classe et je
suis parti à Minneapolis
dernière question et puis on passe à
notre débat
c'était un bon coup
de pied
vous savez qu'il y a une statistique
là-dessus les personnes de taille pas
trop grandes sont ben pardon font mieux
l'amour que les très grands 85 pardon
hein ce qui danse bien ceux qui dansent
bien et ceux qui sont petits
[Applaudissements]
et il y a one man en ce moment où vous
racontez tout ça et avec le même humour
qu'aujourd'hui
mais là vous restez avec nous parce